good morning everybody welcome sanity
planning policy subcommittee meeting as
we have a visitor I think we
appropriately that the emergency
evacuation announcement should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit there is one fire
exit in the true Malcolm that door if
you need to back bedroom please do so
violent blast doors behind George to the
external fire escape staircase please
hold both handrails in case of the
stairs are wet or slippery if anyone is
unable to use the stairs but they please
allow others 20 the room before they go
to the fire escape door where they can
be given assistance our assembly point
is in the public carpark of the sides of
civic suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded could I
please ask you to switch off your mobile
phones or send them to silence all right
moving on apologies for absence from
counselor John Mason who we do - by
Counting hand boy non-members attending
as - Chris Stanley and councillor Ward
we have here OC on item agenda item
number 3 is the minister meeting held on
the 9th of July which if anybody has any
objections to I will sign in due course
if you recall we we did have a meeting
in August but due to technical reasons
that could not be
an official meeting so the meaty the mid
last official minutes we have after the
meeting I'll sign those into of course
any declarations of interest i vont
procure you just as big a portfolio of
your enterprise okay thank you very much
moving on as you see we now have three
separate items my intention is to allow
our offices to I mean I'm assuming that
everybody has read all these ripples to
allow the officers to clarify any points
at which stage after that members will
be invited to ask any questions okay so
is it your Matt oh okay we've got a
statement of community involvement over
to University and so members will be
aware that the council adopted its most
recent stand in a few development in
July 2016 following a period of public
consultation there been a number of
changes over the last couple years in
relation to to legislation merrily in
response to neighborhood planning
amendments and also to data protection
there are three amendments that are
proposed to be consulted on and to
supplement the adopted family community
involvement and the first one relates to
GDP are the new regulations came into
effect in May this year so the addendum
in relation to GDP are is quite short
and despair applies the council's
position with regard to how we deal with
people's personal data the second
amendment is in relation to the South
Wessex joint strategic plan as members
will be aware it counts always committed
to working with its neighbors across
athletics to prepare this joint plan
members adopted the latest timetable and
local development scheme which included
an update on the timetable for
delivering at the joint strategic plan
the LDS was adopted in July this year
and this amendment proposes an agreed
framework for consulting on the
diversity plan once we get to a point of
publishing a draft this would brick this
this amendment has been agreed across
the six South Wessex authorities plus
Essex County Council such posts that we
keep the same format and because this is
consistent with the other assets
authorities at this point in time but we
are proposing again to consult on this
amendment
each local authority will consult on the
amendment as well and then those
responses will be collated and a final
version will be prepared and reported
back to the subcommittee and then for
council a final amendment is in response
to
neighbourhood planning amendments which
came through in the neighborhood
planning act of 2017 main thrust of the
addendum is to provide a bit more detail
on how the neighborhood planning process
works and how the council's will support
that process through consultation etc so
those are the three separate addendums
which we're looking to consult on thank
you well as as you've probably read in
as much as you explain very much most of
this is is what it is please if
anybody's got any questions I'm one ways
with with offices please go ahead
otherwise I don't think there's a limits
what we've got any flexibility on this
situation thank you just a couple issues
should be very simple how many people
were culled from the list
oh man don't work because of anything
they were under GDP or whatever you need
to ask them to stone beliefs don't they
were there for a reason therefore the
reason patty was that the reason we only
we only contact such people who had
never made a representations that's not
really because not to do the pattern is
the list
it was the interpretation of the of JDI
who hold the holder mailing list it was
their interpretation of the new
regulations there's still I think
they're still in an uncertainty as to
what that means and each like Authority
has done something slightly different
but this is the advice that we were
given by the body that it's responsible
for holding our mailing list so that's
the approach that we took based on on
there so people do that never respond
duties they obviously respond you're
returning to building these they they
would have requested at some point to
become a list but some of those
individuals had been on there for 10
years
never made a representation so it's just
to reconfirm really that they're happy
for us to hold their details in
accordance with there's still it was
about 9,000 and somewhere between 500
and 1,000 worth deleted most of those
were I mean a lot of people have ended
up on our mailing list when the joint
area action plan was consulted on so
actually they live in Southend so a lot
of people maybe aren't actually as
interested in Rotenberg planning as as
being on the main list suggests so like
that says just to confirm but they were
happy for us to still contact I think I
don't get audio because I just died yeah
cuz I think anecdotally I had a couple
of emails over time that because of the
joint error action plan and people
starting up to that they you were
questioning why they kept getting
information related to rotted so I think
it's kind of a tidying up process to a
degree on that okay the second question
was read just about the young JSP but
such then we talked about consultation
consultation also changing what is the
JSP and the change of look like talk
about money the dress being has been
already quite a lot of some perhaps
money in groans will they will they will
the a7ii contributing towards the cost
of thinking consultation where is that
going to be born well counsel well I
think two degree that still to be
discussed as the document is developed
because of Xenu of the issues and
options conversations we saw in the
training and and is in the LDS it's not
until next year and there are still some
meetings to take place in relation to
how it will go forward in terms of
consultation so the money that was
awarded so far has related mainly to
evidence-based documents
and sort of putting that information
together so I think that's still an
outstanding issue or item to be
discussed by a seller okay there's no
more questions members we have a
recommendation goes to committee full
council that would draft attendance
apodaca statement of community
involvement and at Appendix A B and C we
consult on for four weeks and that's our
recommendation okay thank you very much
I think before we move on to section
numbers item number 6 it may be
appropriate just in case anybody isn't
aware Matthew here will be leaving us
within the next couple months so I think
it may be appropriate as we progress on
this conversation so I think Natalie or
manually explain what we feel is going
to be the best one head in the
short-term and we may need to adjust
that as time progresses but they would
explain and I'm aware of some of the
issues that we may want to raise so we
don't lose them again okay okay so
second item relates to considering
priorities as we go forward so following
on from what counselor
sparing has been saying with all the
different elements that are coming
forward so we've got the joint strategic
plan we've got the local plan meeting
we've got our duty to cooperate
considerations with our neighboring
authorities and you know highlighted
more recently which is discussed here is
the issue of gypsy and travelers and how
we take that forward
the applications have come forward and
the appeals that have have been
determined in the latest latest two-year
period so this document sort of outlines
where we are in terms of options to go
forward and we've sort of taken these
options forward bearing in mind existing
resource and obviously further resource
going forward considering what the
makeup of the team will be in the next
six months at least as I say with the
joint strategic plan coming forward by
the spring of next year and now where
the local plan sits in consideration
it's a consideration of that and what
needs to be determined by the JSP to
assist the local plan going forward
however you know we're we're aware that
there are other issues that need to be
addressed and whether there are other
issues that need to be addressed in the
short term all these things really have
to go through a local plan process so
that's even if there's allocation of
sites in relation to two gypsy and
traveller issues and if that was thing
to be something that should go forward
ahead of possibly local plan work
obviously the joint strategic plan has a
set timeline and that will go forward as
that is but bearing in mind that the
size of the team we put forward a number
of options that sort of considered
whether we need I would say we probably
do need to prioritize what comes forward
first depending on what members feel are
you know other priorities going forward
for the council so that's set out in the
options going forward I'm a-going to
things in detail but one is sort of just
you know continuing with the local plan
following the JSP work and and that is
sort of where we were considering before
we were thinking about resource issues
and we were thinking about where the JSP
sits and obviously in the appeal
decisions that took place you know when
the gypsy in trouble of sights so far
option two on there just looks at having
kind of a focus document going forward
so maybe not the local plan and all the
elements and the detail that exists in
that but sort of a high-level part one
local plan that just considers the key
sort of strategic policies going forward
the third option is a separate issues
and options discussing sort of gypsy and
traveler policy ahead of the preferred
option document that would exist for the
local plan so this is almost kind of a
document setting the scene we can
consult on that just to get an idea of
the appetite I guess you know from from
from the community going forward and
obviously are you as members about
whether that is an appropriate way
forward to accelerate something ahead of
the local plan to obviously deal with
you know sort of a quite pertinent issue
option for I suppose is a slightly more
accelerated version of that that we know
we we basically do commit to going
forward with that approach because that
should be the priority the a JSP will be
continuing on obviously resources to a
certain degree we'll be concentrating on
that because we have to commit an
officer from first of October for two
days a week that a team who are
preparing that so we got to bear in mind
the resource issue in those terms
whether a separate issues and options
gypsy traveller document is taken
forward ahead of a local plan because
members deem that that's an issue
should be tested ahead of other policies
that could be taken forward as a local
plan following that because some of them
will be dealt with by the joint
strategic plan anyway so those are the
issues before members to discuss and the
options to consider okay thank you
I will bring that's being shortly
because she'll be the longest-serving or
senior officer here in a few months it
might get very clear that senior
management with the council are fully
aware of these issues I've made them
aware I know the portfolio holders by
the way I know the offices of made aware
so it's not as over the issues aren't
being addressed but this is a situation
that we are all in at the moment and I
don't think is any doubt that there will
be a time delay between Matthew leaving
and and another person I mean that's a
reality so before Natalie comes in with
her views on the future has anybody got
any questions they want to raise at this
stage I want my thesis say ooh sorry
crystal policy through through my have
you got something anything listed on my
brother coming to you no okay do you
want to carry on the Nestle
we've had some internal discussions
about what we feel is potentially the
the best approach I know there are there
have been some recent challenges to our
existing policies on the dips and the
dips and Traveller deputy a traveller
from so with with the resources that
we've got we feel that option 3 could
potentially be be delivered in terms of
looking in a bit more detail at how we
seek to meet their needs of Jets and
travelers in a comprehensive Rio Phoenix
in 15 to 20 years
that would probably look in a bit more
detail at existing policy how that
annotation is likely to be delivered if
at all I've minutes or five or 10 years
and what the other options are for us in
reality looking a bit more detail as
well as sites that come forwards through
the through the cooler sites and other
sites that we may be able to identify
and try to firm up our approach to to
realistically meeting meeting the needs
based on the most recent evidence in the
and the ships in travel accommodation
assessment that does give us the
opportunity so once we've prepared a
specific issues paper we do have the
option then to consult on that and look
at their responses and then bring it
back to the subcommittee and from that
point on then decide whether we still
want to progress with the complete local
plan including all of those issues
together or whether we then go down the
route of doing a separate gypsum
traveller policy document as a priority
and it will be dependent on resources at
each point in time we don't quite know
how the
our team is going to be shaping up over
the next six to twelve months so
whatever option members do decide the
best approach we just need to keep that
under review and make sure that we are
meeting our overall targets the risks of
each potential option is I think quite
quite clearly set out there are risks
with each option even going forward with
just a local plan because you are
looking at all of those issues together
if one issue can't be resolved then the
whole plan is that risk but likewise if
we consider if we continue to maybe look
at one particular issue on its own again
with resourcing issues in particular the
local plan and thus the other issues
would be put would be set aside for
perhaps for a period of time and the
risks that come with that we know that
our neighboring authorities in South
Wessex have been identified by the
government for consideration for
intervention and we know that there is
another list coming out and I believe
November with other local searches that
can be identified by the government any
local authority that is identified on
that list if then clearly on the
government's radar be subject to two
regular meetings with with
representatives of the government and
they will be more closely scrutinizing
our timetable and they would want to
know clearly why there's any slippage
why we're taking a particular approach
so whatever whatever option we take
forward we need to be clearly we need to
be very clear why we're taking that
approach and Polly accepting the risks
risks that go with that as well
exhibition em gypsy traveller say Oh
obviously the preferred option was
machines farm is are we saying you don't
have bags look at other options for this
well I would say bearing in mind the
guidance and the approach that
government deemed that we should be
taking our sins adoption of that plan
obviously that went through independent
examination inspectors report that said
that was a deemed fit for purpose I at
the time you know at the time it has a
job to do so it was prior to the new
guidance that has come out in 2015 so if
we bear that in mind so now the approach
is that they should rather than one site
but we did meet our need at the time
because it was 15 and we set aside for
15 but now they want to see a sort of a
more multifaceted approach so that you
have options and different sites
different sizes so you have public sites
and private sites and different sites to
accommodate the the needs of gypsy
travelers so that's the issue that we
we're now dealing with so michelin's on
its own as a site at the time that it
was adopted was considered as
appropriate and now with the changing
legislation and guidance we need to
explore other options and clearly the
delivery of that site it's proving
difficult so the policy was there but
delivering that policy is the difficulty
because you know we we need someone to
be on board to be able to take that site
forward and deliver it now if we had a
different approach in the future where
we had a number of different sites that
would take on board possibly gypsy
traveller need if they wish to own your
own site then we would have allocations
which they could purchase you know and
then the other case
purpose and then that would have an
effect on what is happening at the
moment with sights coming forward and
gaming temporary Commission or or
winning one appeal with an Italian
inspector a good person
pretty much the state was obviously
since the approval for the previous plan
which had which means going there
there's obviously upgrades to the AE 130
92 7 Junction now would appear to poster
board of Rome South I think he's just
Common Pleas just north or south the
railway line but it's around the area
with the rotating through its own become
even when that really hasn't been taken
account of either use way it has been
taken account of and Essex County
Council has been aware of that
allocation for quite a few years now so
when they were drawing up the potential
options for improvements at the
fairground junction they did do some
initial design work to accommodate that
that site as a whole being being
delivered for both employment and ships
and travel uses so they are very much
aware of that so the whole scheme have
taken the delivery of that sort into
account and the land allocations as a
whole yeah when we're talking about that
they have been planning permissions
granted on appeal I know there's a
couple would work the permanent but I
think the last two I think of thing my
peers think nothing says in report that
they would judge me based on the fact
family reasons like young children on
the basis that regardless of the stage
dragons the mechanically making quicker
rather than slow oven I'm just going to
ask if they would still be parks because
obviously if you you're getting
Commission based on a family need at
that point in time
she might have young children at school
they they can't wait five years or ten
years with the plan to come today
Germany will still be likely to be
passed on I think I'm correct in
thinking that until we progress a plan -
you know that's that's the thing because
there is still a time period that it
takes to deliver a plan so and then have
sites that are deliverable so I think
that's why on the last cases you know
the inspector apart from whether there
was the PDL where it was you know a
different decision was made with those
temporary permissions if if and when
they do come forward it's based on that
because the inspector is considering the
timeline that it would take to produce a
document that would allow us to have
sites allocated for that purpose and how
far towards kind of do we are they like
wooden full-size ones which would be
passed already we can ignore them going
forward or they call down and say we
haven't provided a solution and other
sites so I I would say if you look at
our latest assessment of need which was
January 2018 that was looking at our
jibsen traveler population at that time
and what these specific needs would be
both to effectively plan for the
unauthorized sites but also taking to
account the concealed in other
households that would need their own
site or own pitch at a period of time
the two most recent applications are or
effectively on top of that because they
weren't there when we were doing our
initial assessment they would in theory
be in addition to that and we are
looking at updating our baseline again
through reviewing existing chips and
Traveller policies not only would we be
looking to to allocate based on evidence
from a point in time we would also be
looking at some sort of criteria based
policy as well to try and capture those
sites which fall out outside
is arriving just wake up throw in favor
of option three you think personally
issues until totally suffers work on
there's nothing we should be seen to be
doing it properly and to actually get
some meaningful okay before we go out
there might be another question question
yes oh no no no because something about
they did they make some comments on that
heightened elevation is is really about
that being specific now photography is
not relevant is the site sir the end of
the junction of of say growth Laden da
one two four five which was refused
permission and it's been refuted I think
is being upheld how does how panel does
or doesn't that theme to any of these
that's a very open question I don't know
is it
yes when their ears absolutely we can
look in some detail at each of those
sites that's the normal thrice site so
we can look at how that fits into our
overall delivery plan if you like of
meeting needs we can look at these the
specific issues in relation to it the
planning history etc and we can through
the policy process through the
consultation as well determine if we
fill them again I find the other side is
you would have to go through that
process to understand where it was
deliverable suitable but if for example
if an or an authorized site if we
consider it to be suitable it's been
there a period of time and we were
looking to allocate that that would then
mean that we wouldn't need to find a
site elsewhere to meet those needs so it
would contribute yeah
as we say we are updating our baseline
at the moment so they will have a fresh
response to what that mean is okay well
in light of the comments from from
Natalie and Matthew I would suggest that
we support their recommendation for
option number three members are great
but I also think we should put at this
point you know all of this is is
dependent upon resources being made
available I think we should include date
now recommendation in Sirte for council
if it were in agreement
I have to say we we are definitely I was
sure whose name we that I said me a
minute
for us not to slip into that with
the stronger wealthier thing but it's
naturally highlight you do obviously
central government is looking at South
Essex councils don't no doubt about that
you know they've got three on the right
are already even so they're focused here
so I think it was will do is come up
with you know we can forget his foe's
subcommittee recommends to council a
local plan should progress in the short
to medium term with option three as
stated in this like that subcommittee
expresses its strong concerns regarding
the resources that are currently
available and look to be made available
in the short term subcommittee is
concerned that central government is
highlighting councils in its our basics
and we feel it is essential that we do
not come under there closer scrutiny
yeah members happy with that okay thank
you very much we'll move on then to be
honest no Sonya then when we want to
item number seven I mean we've been
talking about the program ahead I think
as you're aware we found over the last
couple of months and I will continue to
have monthly meetings but there are
occasions thanks you for coming there
are occasions where we have updates for
information purposes only and there are
other meetings whether we need to make
recommendations so I'll just pass over
to Sonya who's got some ideas on this
and and how we have to move forward so
that we don't necessarily have to get
everybody here or do we need to do I
think that given that you expressed I
think only early on and similarly the
desire to meet on a regular basis we can
still do that and I will continue to
contact your water to get those meetings
in the diary but I think I think it
would make more sense and where you
haven't got any formal
human nations into PowerSchool in terms
of you know consultations or needing to
turn things around birthday that we have
we have more informal meetings and you
know that sort of agendas and so on and
then obviously when you need to look at
things and make recommendations and
those meetings will come for ones and
say mister days but we would still have
a monthly meeting and it'll just be what
never leads being appraised that yeah
every been happening okay let's move on
to item number seven and I think we need
to you know skip through this very
individually some of which of these
items would just be to know others we
may want to make comment on so do you
want to lean on this Natalie yeah yeah
and so this report is basically an
update to the one which you would
hopefully read that was published in
August so it follows exactly the same
format just going through each of the
each of the items first ones the local
variants game will need to work on
updating that now because of your your
decision on item six because we're
looking at another specific consultation
we will need to update that and I'll
just say that that's factored in but
we're suppose we are meant to review
that on a regular basis anyway cuz
anything Jess etc and that's something
that we'll we'll look at doing and
trying to work up a timetable for for
delivering that specific issues paper
the consultation feedback report issues
an options document we're hoping to
present that to the the next meeting of
the subcommittee
late October winner Konami yep again
there has been some Samana
- lippisch that unfortunately and we had
to earn some quite significant IT issues
for example which meant that we couldn't
actively work on on that report and
delivery in time for this committee
unfortunately we've briefly mentioned
the gdpr and and the cleanse that our
mailing list has gone through we still
have a substantial number of individuals
and organizations on that and we are
looking to send out more regular a
bulletins I think on a bi-monthly basis
they just apply brief updates to those
that are interested in planning matters
the again the joint strategic plan we
have touched on as well the latest LDS
anticipates publication of the first
consultation draft in the spring of next
year and as Matthew has already
highlighted and there will be an officer
working on that from the council for for
two days a week effective on the first
of October again the site between two
involvement we will now be looking to
consult on those three addendums that
members have agreed at some point before
Christmas so we should be able to update
you with that at the next subcommittee
as well
again neighborhood planning we've
covered that briefly in under item five
there's been no update to to the August
work program we still just have kanuda
who's interesting for racing an able
plan but they haven't come back to us
recently with with any updates or Ausmus
to review anything we're still
maintaining the brownfield and self and
custom build registers there's no update
from my list moving on to the evidence
based documents the like the wildlife
sites review we're hoping to bring it to
this subcommittee but it wasn't wasting
time unfortunately so you will be able
to consider that at the at the next
subcommittee meeting playing pitch
strategy that's still progressing and we
anticipate that to be finished
later on in the year again we're
bringing that in front of the
subcommittee and that provide a bit more
detail on the findings and the outcomes
and recommendations of that both the
landscape from the the Greenbelt
assessment have been commissioned and
those documents are progressing get more
keep members updated on basically how
they saw how those are shaping up but
they should be completed later on in
2018 the great vacation study to support
the JSP and it's been some slight
slippage in the timetable for that
evidence-based document but we should be
bringing it before supplements before
the end of the year
just touching on the last two pieces of
work say the the Sheila we've had a
number of additional sites which have
been put forward which we need to
consider and we're likely going to
Commission consultant to undertake that
piece of work bringing together the work
that we've already done from their twin
2017 study and the name of new evidence
as well so hopefully that should be
completed before the end of the year as
well so bring that font of members and
we'll have that new evidence to support
both leave the preferred options
document and the ASP as well and then
finally the brands that dance been
labeled from for watching side again
there's an SPG that's going to be
produced which which will be presented
to members in juniors as well the final
thing is consultation so responded to
PowerPoint consultation
most recently over the next six months
there are going to be a significant
number of consultations Frost respond to
as well we've got costal pointing at
bathroom and Brent we've got a listen to
consult with various stages so that's
going to be a it's going to be a bit of
a challenge for us to clarify on these
other points that's the obvious
implications and just go slowly I thank
very much to say here than we
yet we've touched on government
intervention so it relates back to
really to keep now LDS up to date and
being quite clear but the reasons for
any sort of slippage is why we're doing
additional consultation so I would take
an additional approach etc and just
being clear how that will impact on
other aspects of plan making as well the
through authorities I've just named are
those that are subject to government
scrutiny so again we just need to work
quite closely within as part of the JSP
to make sure that we are delivering what
we what we should be delivering in there
at the right time only just add
obviously the the update with what is
useful and it just highlights the
additional work that happens behind the
scenes and the amount of work that's
required in the preparation of the
different documents that take place so
while you see sort of the local plans
you know on the surface you know all
those deadlines and dates that we need
to prepare them there's all that work
going on in the background so you know
while the plans aren't taking place you
know the team are frantically sort of
arranging doing studies preparing
evidence base work so that there's a
whole ream of work that happens a lot of
different levels when you sort of don't
hear about the main consultations taking
place and it's just probably worth just
highlighting that and I think that's
what's good about this update report it
just it just gives a flavor an idea of
what the team has to sort of produce in
those intervening periods so okay
there's obviously June a system in
common
going in highlights losing two days a
week put it simply to remember the team
which is a small team anyway actually be
concentrating on the JSP she went the
other one yes yes damn that starts his
last term so we're losing him one day
we're gonna be down to two diets no
already so many others I am so well I
think that's what we're gonna put in
here mine thank you sure you would
expect someone to ask this question um
what's the risk of a new road from C I
think I can get one he's obviously seems
to be currently favored in South End is
that risk to our plans is in is it just
something we're taking care of with a
mental process of doing this work I
would say it's something that would need
to be discussed because it would be if
it was and even if it was viable it's a
major piece of infrastructure and so it
must be something that would need to be
highlighted and discussed at the joint
strategic plan level because of the
nature and scope of it so although
strategic transport infrastructure
options they will need to be considered
at that level so when that consultation
comes around and if it's something that
is considered you know as a piece of
infrastructure to help deliver
employment housing whatever it might be
then it's something that needs to be
raised at that level so as part of that
consultation process my mind is
something which presumably is going to
be wanted to be put in there by Southend
from whatever it from my space from
there's newspaper reports I guess down
platform in thinking is there deputy
leader wasn't in who
so it was at the end of a significant
effect on what we respond something to
usually vote is just wondering how we go
into this that's that's a process it
would be at a higher level I think I'll
be interested to read the playing each
strategy because what I'm leaving and I
know he's done only practice are two
entirely different things but that's a
purely personal issue again if we have
read that s anybody got any other
questions we have a recommendation for
these teaching planning planning teams
responsibilities of unity teamwork
extreme would be noted subject to
resource constraints I think that gain
we need to emphasize some wording that
we to the effect that we totally
appreciate the update that we've given
on a monthly basis now but yet again we
express our concerns that what is being
asked of the treaty was your official
title strategic planning regeneration
economic generation team is being
stretched to the limit what they're
being asked
members though in agreement with that
totally yep didn't honey I think members
that's it
waiting roses at 10:15